hey guys my name is Jeff it is the
eighth of august and the new guy is
filming today so let's all be extra
night hello games founder Sean mari
appears to be tampering expectations for
no man's sky as he said the game will be
super divisive and not for everyone a
recent blog post detailed exactly what
it is you do in the game he listed
exploring a universe of procedurally
generated worlds trading combat in space
and on land crafting and survival he
explained that means this maybe isn't
the game you imagined from those
trailers if you hoped for things like
the PvP multiplayer or city building
piloting freighters or building
civilizations that isn't what no man's
sky is over time it might become some of
those things through updates adding that
freight and base building are indeed on
their way on the whole though Murray
says you're primarily in store for an
infinite procedural sci fi space
survival sandbox he later clarified on
Twitter to be super clear no man's sky
is not a multiplayer game please don't
go in looking for that experience no
man's sky arrives tomorrow a bunch of
you are really excited about the Skyrim
remaster but there was still quite a few
people like me who were asking why not
oblivion well now Bethesda have a dress
patch but there's a marketing boss Pete
Hines told gamespot oblivion is 10 years
old so the amount of work for that
engine and that tech to bring it and
remaster it and do all the things we
wanted to do was significant it's not
impossible but it was mountainous it was
either like go and make an entire new
game or do Skyrim Hines added that
Skyrim already had a huge audience and
was the company's most successful game
before fallout 4 he also spoke about how
mods will work for the Skyrim remaster
when it arrives later this year
essentially it's exactly the way they
work for full that floor and there will
be a new mod creation kit existing mods
can work but they will need to have been
run through the new creation kit and
published on potatoes
that finally Sony won't let dinosaur
survival game Ark survival evolved
beyond ps4 according to the studio
developer studio wild card put up a
forum post that read as for the ps4
release of Ark survival evolved it is
currently up to Sony we've been informed
that we can't release the game on this
platform until it has been finished we
would like nothing more than to make our
cavaillon ps4 as soon as possible as we
already have an awesome ps4 version of
the game running internally if you'd
like to see soon up please let sony know
as it's unfortunately not our decision
survival evolved is available on Steam
early access and on Xbox one through
game preview however the ps4 doesn't
have a program to make in development
games playable let me know in that
comment box if you'd like to see sony
make in development games available head
to gamespot for stories on doom and
pokemon go getting banned and i'll be
back with more news tomorrow